apologies to Matt Damon ran out of time
Matt Damon apologies ran out of time Dr
Phil teaches us that when the roost
sorry Campbell
please say hello to Dr Phil
what are you doing here what do you mean
what is going on here well I'm not
touching you oh
okay so that's a real question I'll ask
it oh no that is the fire alarm he
thinks the world revolves around him he
thinks he's the only celebrity in
California nothing could ruin this
moment this is a very special the sweet
we can't wait to see you out what is
this I'm the father send um I'm actually
hold on a second
so sorry he's not supposed to go into
the guest rooms he has his own area that
he's
playing
okay no
I'm on the show oh that's pretty funny
no I ran out of time for you what's that
Jimmy
huh